let's get...
[snickers]
Ha-ha-ha.
L-O-L.
Very funny, guys.
And blastoff!
Let's start by asking
a simple question:
why are we here?
- Shouldn't you know
the answer to that?
- Of course, Baron.
Because that was
a rhetorical question.
- Okay.
We just need to brainstorm
five ideas.
- But to be safe,
let's come up with 50.
- Let's make it 100!
- Any idea is welcome
when brainstorming.
Literally anything you say
will be discussed
in detail without criticism.
- My brain just stormed an idea.
How about
we call off this meeting
until Christian gets back?
- Come on, that's a bad idea.
- I thought we weren't gonna
criticize ideas.
- Fine. Yeah.
Let's put it on the board.
[clears throat]
- Any other ideas?
- We're going into
a brainstorm hole.
I can literally
say anything right now.
Racism.
- Racism.
Great idea.
- Nice.
- Jesus Christ,
this is a nightmare.
- What's that, Matt?
- Oh, I just said
that this is a nightmare.
- This is a nightmare.
Great.
- You know, this reminds me
of when I was selling
cigarettes wholesale
to health food stores
back in the '70s.
At the time, we didn't know
they were bad for you.
Or, actually, we did know,
but we kept a lid on it.
Back then, you were allowed
to have secrets.
Secrets from the government,
from your wife.
It didn't matter!
- I hope my grandma died
doing what she loved most:
sitting in her chair,
worrying that I'm gay.
- Your grandma's lucky.
When you're dead, nobody
expects anything from you.
Death is
the retirement package you get
for a lifetime full
of pain and suffering.
- That's why I say
you should always bring a gun
to a knife fight,
or a knife to a gun fight,
if you wish.
Now, you might die,
but at least no one can say
you weren't interesting.
- Thank you...
so much, Bill.
Very helpful.
Does anyone have
a coherent idea?
- Hey, guys?
Guys!
Can we get off our phones
and focus up?
- You know, we didn't
used to have phones in meetings.
Back then, if you wanted
to send someone a nudie pic,
you had to show up at their door
wearing just a trench coat
and show them what you got!
Your thoughts?
- Yeah, well, Bill makes
a good point here.
Um...
Oh.
Here's an idea.
How about
we try something new
and have everyone in the room
put their phones
in this box.
[screaming]
- No!